what I wanted to demonstrate is this how
this press works I want to show you how
to make a water a proper water filter
and this is ceramic water filter that
I'm going to create here and that's
essentially a focus of the first talk
this is a bisque fired filters made with
clay and sawdust dry clay dry sawdust
about 50/50 and when the sawdust burns
out it leaves pores now the clay is
naturally porous but the sawdust allows
for more porosity and so the water can
flow through if you have water that's
contaminated with microbes and pathogens
that might create things like cholera
coli Giardia you can put that water into
this filter a filter about one to three
liters an hour and that water is
rendered renders about 95 percent free
of those those contaminants we add a
small amount of colloidal silver to the
filter by brushing it on usually it's a
less than a gram with about 500
milliliters of water that silver acts as
a natural antimicrobial and will render
in earth to approximately the remaining
four four and a half to five percent of
the bad stuff that's in that water so
this is one of those approaches that
allows us to have potable water or
adequate access to clean water a few
years ago I was working with some
undergrad engineering students and I
said look I have this dilemma
here's the here's the situation with
this big press that's used
conventionally to make these filters but
it's really tough to to take with me on
the road can you make one that fits in a
suitcase they say yeah can you make one
that makes the same size filters yeah
can you make one that doesn't cost any
money or cost as little as possible they
said well wait maybe and they did it
this is the the filter press it was
collapsed earlier I assembled this and
they made this out of repurposed
materials but also some of the materials
I gave them which was this Bell the male
and female molds here so I'll
demonstrate how this this works to make
a filter usually again the filters are
made on a full-sized press but this is a
smaller press
so this is both the prototype and the
final product and the only one in
existence cool thing about this is one
person can operate it usually with those
big presses it's easier if two people
operates it but one person can do very
well so this is a male mold this is
essentially very lightweight steel this
is so we have this is this Bell form and
what we're going to do is put the clay
in the middle and we'll make the filter
this way so this is this is the the
metal mold the bottom of the mold I'm
going to put this thank you put this
plastic down as release agent because
the clay will stick to the metal won't
doesn't like to stick to the plastic and
have this bat there's a bevel in it and
approximate the same angle as the the
Bell then I'm gonna put this clay so I'm
gonna put the second piece of plastic on
and then I'll put the this top part
what's interesting is that the original
traditional approach to these larger
presses used concrete molds and then
they move to light later weight metal
molds and so this is the same exact mold
that one would find on a larger press
now this is the part that sometimes gets
tricky because you got to make sure both
of these sides are latched down take
this arm and tighten up the the jack and
then with just a simple
this is a fun part I like to say you
have to get up to get down right you
have to push this thing up in order for
it to have resistance and push back down
at this point I am going to release the
pressure
certainly this machine this press
portable press wouldn't necessarily work
well for a proper production facility
where you want to crank out lots of
filters in a day or in a week but
certainly to establish a facility in a
community that needs clean water using
this technology we can use this press to
create filters very quickly and create
give us a give ourselves a baseline of
not only the clay but the how the
filtration works lift this back up take
the bell off there's our filter just
takes a little bit of clean up at this
point again I'm using my thumb just to
pull some of this extra off but I could
certainly use and this is what you would
do in a the production facility would be
to take a clay Tolan to clean this up as
well and then because this bat is wider
than the base I simply lift and there's
the filter I can lay this place this
down on a shelf in the studio or in the
facility another worker would clean it
up smooth up some of the edges perhaps
stamp it with a date and a number so we
can track the way that it put it
operates we let it dry then we fire we
put it in the kiln we fired to about 860
six degrees C and what happens then is
the sawdust burns out which then creates
a more porous vessel that allows the
water to flow at a more rapid pace than
it would if it wasn't as porous this is
ready to make another filter I could put
plastic down another bat down we could
continue to make filters as long as we
had clay so with one person that was
what about a ten minute time frame with
two people you could move much more
quickly but the reason I wanted to
demonstrate this to you is to show you
in real time what it takes to create a
water filter what if you designed houses
what if you designed shelters what if
you designed access to water as if you
really cared about people getting it not
that you cared about making money from
it or that you were interested in fame
or that you were just doing it to do it
what if you gave a damn about the
situation what if he cared in in more
direct ways what would that look like in
ways that would be affordable to people
who need it but also appropriate in
terms of appropriate technology the idea
that materials and practices and
processes that allow for things like
shelter and food and water access to
happen do not complicate a cultural set
of rules and practices right it's
appropriate for the culture it's
appropriate for the situation thinking
about culture as the way we do things
around here right so does the cup does
the technology interrupt the way we do
things around and does it pose confusion
so this is the gentleman who invented or
was credited with coming up with the
approach that dr. Fran dimas' Regas he's
from Guatemala and as a first response
to natural disasters Missouri Gustad if
we had this porous vessel that allowed
for water to flow through that the
contaminated water to flow through at a
fairly rapid pace we might be able to
produce adequate access to clean water
to potable water after natural disasters
and so Mazza Regas then
was contacted by Ron Rivera Ron was
working with Potter's for peace at the
time and this was in the late 80s early
90s and Ron learned the process and
started setting up water filter
production facility through Potter's for
peace met Ron Rivera a number of years
ago at a conference and several months
late after I met him he passed away he
was working in Nigeria to help a
community set up a water filter
production facility so that they
wouldn't contract malaria and would not
die from malaria Ron came back from that
trip and died from a very rare and
difficult strain of malaria so he gave
his life so that others could have clean
water and whenever I give a presentation
I always think of that very special
moment meeting Ron but the idea is that
it's possible for this technology to be
passed along to folks so that they can
add use it to to move throughout world
the world and through communities to to
to help other other people this is a
cross-section there's a drawing that
Manny did of the filter inside the
receptacle you see the addition of a
spigot and a lid and these are two
important components you need a spigot
to get the water out and a lid to keep
hands and other things entering into the
into the filter contamination is is a
big issue right these filters as you see
here if they were sitting in a count on
a counter in a kitchen you can put
anything in the your hands can touch
them external things could touch them
and and you can contaminate the water
even the water that is flowing through
can get contaminated so a lid is
necessary I don't know if you can hear
but this one is dripping quite loudly
now that the water is flowing we have
some dirty water that we were using
earlier and we filled these filters up
I'm going to lift this one up so you can
see it okay you can't see the
cross-section this is the cross-section
here's the spigot I don't have the lid
but I'll lift this up you'll notice the
bell shape and you should see the water
dripping from the filter
you see that and if you come up later
after we give this little chat you'll be
able to see the clean water that's in
there so this is a point of views water
filter it's placed in the point in which
it will be used in the home usually in a
kitchen and you the idea is that you
would fill it up in the morning or in
the evening I'm sorry before you go to
sleep it will filter through the night
and in the morning you have water for
cooking and drinking you fill it up
again sometime during the day and then
you have another batch of water in the
evening so again point of views water
filters these filters again the
technology is the same the idea is the
same but because clay and needs are
different in different locations various
organizations have set up facilities
under different names but using the same
technology the same idea because the
need for clean water is a global need
the right to what access to water is a
basic human right so this little girl
and her the other two children in the
image are drinking water like they do
every day I can go right to that water
fountain down the hallway and get a
drink of water where my water bottle is
here somewhere I can drink out of that
you know many of you have water bottles
this is the same water that you see in
the background this water is the same
water where the cows have defecated
where people have thrown away whatever
it is they're throwing away in that
water this little girl is in Honduras
this gentleman is getting water for his
family as well and that box has a little
opening on the face on the plane facing
us he reaches his hand and puts a few
coins in there and the water comes out
of that long tube water's been sitting
in some sort of receptacle reservoir
underneath he fills up the containers in
the back of his truck and then drives
those containers home then has to figure
out how to get the water into his house
and that's to figure out how to get make
sure the water is clean and safe to
drink this gentleman is in South Texas
outside of Laredo half a million people
do not have utilities paved roads and
housing that's up to code in South Texas
from El Paso to Brownsville and 150
miles north at green swath that you see
in that map that's South Texas half a
million people they don't have adequate
access to clean water either and so my
colleague at Texas A&M Oscar muñoz is is
the director of the colonias program and
works with communities along that along
that region social practice and public
pedagogy linking those to this notion of
inter intentionally disruptive
responsibility social practice being a
term that grows out of a number of moves
in contemporary art where we have been
theorized by people like Clare Bishop
and Pablo ellebra
and others to think about the way in
which artists or our artistic practices
intersect with social issues and
conventions from other disciplines to
make positive change or to enact change
in through intentional amongst public
pedagogy very much like what we did this
after this morning we were out
essentially on the sidewalk now we're on
the patio that overlooked the sidewalk
mixing clay and sawdust in preparation
for making water filters and people
stopped and said what do you when what
are you doing right there you have
developed a relationship this
interchange by asking a question and
responding in this back and forth and
back and forth there's some learning
that goes on in both directions and
talking to folks about the water filters
through a public forum in a public space
is one form that we might consider
public pedagogy and when I moved it to
Penn State I decided to put a name to
these performances collaborative
creative resistance I mean Larry and I
were talking about titles and sometimes
the titles enough to tease and pull
folks in but the idea of how might we
collaboratively work together to resist
those hegemonic forces or to disrupt
what others might find acceptable so
with a small grant from the Institute
for the Arts and Humanities I did a
performance in front of the
Palmer Museum of Art so there's a
proximity to the museum Art Museum so
maybe it's more art like because it's
closer to the museum I'm not necessarily
saying that but it was a wonderful open
space that allowed for the middle of
campus to to stumble upon and I was it
was a Friday afternoon in the middle of
April set up the press started making
filters people stopped by students in
art education and in the School of
Visual Arts volunteered to sieve sawdust
and to mix the clay although I knew this
would probably happen I didn't count on
it happening to the degree that it did
in the background of this image and in
the very foreground you probably see
people who are a little younger than
what you might expect to see on college
campuses these are children who came
from the local daycare center on campus
and from the local elementary schools
the day care folks knew I was gonna do
it because I had talked to them but the
people the kids from the elementary
schools their teachers and the kids
thought they were going inside the
museum to see art but when they got off
the bus and they saw this guy with the
fedora wedging clay and using this big
guillotine looking machine in the middle
of campus they would have they'd rather
stay outside and talk to that guy we had
wonderful conversations about adequate
access to clean water former student Sam
Bachman who's a ceramic artist
dual-degree studio art and art education
you can have class anywhere you can
engage education anywhere you can have
learning anywhere if education is a
relationship teaching and learning is a
relationship that's negotiated between
multiple parties and there's as much
learning going on from whoever thinks
they might be the teacher as there is
from folks who might initially think
they're the learner everyone in that
relationship is learning and teaching
simultaneously
you